suspected of carrying drugs ryan coloco
was arrested with some force he didn't
have any drugs but was still strip
searched and spent the night in a cell
does he think a new action plan from
police will eradicate their racism this
is something that's going to continue to
happen unfortunately but i just feel
like public pressure has made them have
to look into this i do personally think
that you know it's going to be like they
have done in the past where they're just
going to put a report out for the sake
of it to show that they're you know
doing something about it but i'm not
very confident about what they say
despite
you know them sharing their willingness
to get this out
two years ago the murder of black
suspect george floyd by a police officer
in america prompted a huge wave of
anti-racism rallies across the uk
protesters claims of discrimination by
police here was backed by statistics
the number of people per thousand
stopped and searched by police black 54
white six
and arrests per thousand black sixty
white seventeen
such disparity can't be readily
explained say chief constables but they
understand the distrust among black
communities we recognize that there is
racism bias and discrimination in
policing we absolutely accept many
people do think the police are
institutionally racist we know that
through the engagement we've done and
that's the reality of where we are and
what this plan is about is about saying
okay our job through our actions and
through this work is to demonstrably
prove we're not police chiefs promise
zero tolerance of racism and mandatory
training on racism and black history
they aim to boost recruitment and
retention of black officers and improve
support for black victims of crime
and there's an independent board to
scrutinize their action plan
they'll need to work really closely with
police and crime commissioners with
members of their communities with
anti-racism groups and so yeah it will
be a challenge because they'll need to
bring people along with them
in the journey as well
chief constables insist their national
action plan isn't simply a woke exercise
and will invite public and expert
comment before it's implemented
martin brunt sky news